here's the debate
you're upset they're saying we believe
i thought
yeah
i i almost you know it wasn't there
david david
he said i know
you know who he
is because i follow this kind of stuff
yeah because i follow him hello
mathematician theological philosopher he
he met with zolinski of course
what do you mean with zilinski but by
the way he's in the ukraine in that
world why don't we bring that up in that
world david is like gentlemen we're live
we are right okay hey hello yeah so get
your facts right anyways today's guest
today's guest today's guest today guest
is
ethan sipley
um the best way to describe ethan sipley
is i've watched you know man uh what's
it called remember the titans i don't
know how many times i've watched it how
many often do you quote remember the
titans i told the kids my boys it was
one of the mandatory movies to watch
before they get to watch any other
movies i sat him down and i had him
watch remember the titans dylan is in
love with the movie which is great
that's a great movie but here here's a
lineup
you've uh done movies with denzel three
edward movies three movies with denzel
edward norton in american history x
which is one of the craziest movies of
all time sick movie incredible acting
one of the best monologues that one
whole scene johnny depp
uh leo gosling kutcher jude law
uh
mcconaughey i can go on and on and on i
don't know if i worked with mcconnell
yeah
a wolf of wall street you're the wolf of
wall street leo i forgot about it and i
forgot that i worked with mcconaughey
you know tuesday just just this morning
i was sitting there
listening to on repeat ain't no mountain
high with my kid my kid was dancing i
listened to it over and over and maybe
we'll perform it today i don't know
but he's done a lot of different things
but most uh recently not recently 21 20
21 years you went from 530 pounds to
260 pounds lost thousand pounds give or
take because you would lose you again
you've spoken about this openly
and we'll get into that as well but an
absolute stunt of a guy ethan thank you
for joining the podcast thanks for
having me guys yes the podcast started
10 minutes ago we talked about a lot of
other things
you left off my name is earl that's
where you'd see him on tv all the time
with uh was that jason lee yeah what a
guy i grew up on that show yeah really
yeah in norway all the time all the time
100 percent in norway yeah we got to
know we got fans in norway surprising
hello
yeah well we we were working on uh kai
on a different issue this morning uh
because of david berlinski yesterday
david's trying to walk through the back
and kai's like yeah go ahead go behind
me like get up and let this man get
through and sit but anyway so it's good
to have you on man it's good to have you
good to be here can i tell you the crazy
story yeah yeah i want to hear the story
because this is this story scares me
so it's 19.99 now i'm telling you i'm
timing it because it's like late 2000
early 2001. i'm in debt 49 000
break up girl
nothing's going right in my life i'm
thinking about going back to the army
i've been out of the army for like a
year and a half
i'm drinking like you wouldn't believe
like i'm i'm trying to break records and
i broke a lot of records in the army but
i'm like i'm going all out right
partying and i'm coming back from
outside the garden of eden or it's
dublin's or
it's a a palace or
one of those
key it's not a
it's not the other one in city of
industry what was that one uh the
century club this is all in l.a but i'm
in hollywood and you live in l.a to be
clear i i did i would never have gone as
east as the century club so it must have
been one of these it was it wasn't
century club so i'm coming up and is it
is it fountain i don't know what that
fountain and last that whole when you go
this way you hit the five freeway
there's a chevron right there i go to
the chevron it's two o'clock in the
morning maybe three o'clock in the
morning i am
gone okay but i got to fill up the gas
tank okay
and i get out and i see you i'm like hey
and you're gone
look
literally
he is
i don't know what you were on but i'm
like dude this guy can't even walk
straight i can't walk straight i'm like
you're good i'm good i was a mess yeah
so that was that was an end of 2000 2001
like [ __ ] i freaking see you everywhere
it's like what's up bro
and then we just went on a separate way
just for a minute i was like yeah it was
a 30-second conversation and then i just
i left because but uh yeah that was in
late 2000 early 2001 yeah i don't know
if you were partying back there that was
moments before my last trip to rehab
really yeah that was moments before last
trip to rehab yeah and the last one was
the last one that worked that was the
last time what was different between
that one and the other ones
you know i
i i don't really know i think i think
the the difference was um i had been to
rehab
a few times based on like friends
sitting me down or my parents sitting me
down and going we're really concerned
about you and me going like okay i'll go
do what you're telling me to do and
the last time i went i woke up one day
and was like i don't want to do this
anymore this is no longer fun what did
you go to rehab for
heroin
boom right not even drinking eating all
that no i never went to rehab for eating
i didn't even know those existed i think
they do i probably should have gone but
that that took a little bit longer i had
to get sober before i could like
actually work on my health and my
physicality and what was i'm sorry no i
mean
heroin holy [ __ ] what was that like
uh
in the
in the uh in the earlier 90s i was given
vicodin as a prescription and the the
first time i took vicodin i just felt
like
this is my antidepressant this is my
this is this is the state that i feel
more comfortable in and so when that ran
out i got another prescription i
eventually started they had um you know
storefronts in the 90s down
uh near downtown where you could go in
and buy vicodin for like a dollar a pill
in l.a yeah
um and then eventually it got hard to
buy there so you know you you get
creative and you wind up like well
you wind up finding out that heroin is
just like the best form of vicodin and
and it's much easier to get than vicodin
too in fact so that's how i wound up on
the herald you're a full-on actor in
hollywood at this point yeah full-on
yeah like not you know
small roles like you're doing movies
hollywood yeah
ethan is is it easier or was it the the
drug connection that had happened
through hollywood parties or was it no
it was outside france you know other
contexts there were no i mean
you know what i'm saying like it's the
influence i'm hanging out with hollywood
i'll try some of this okay let's try no
okay no
yeah cocaine is probably i don't know
what's acceptable now i've been sober 20
years so i have no idea what the kids
are doing now and and i would be
terrified to be entering into drug use
now with the amount of overdose there's
with fentanyl mixed in with everything
like that
scares the [ __ ] out of me um
but i never
went walked into people doing heroin at
a party it was it was pretty taboo
yeah but by the way just just out of
curiosity what was harder to do
was it was it tougher to give up uh the
heroine or was it tougher to lose the
weight which one was tougher and were
both motivations the same is it like
fear of death is it is it a girl in your
life is it family is it i just got a
change is it a spiritual moment what
what was it what were the differences
well i i i think about it in different
ways i think that um
drugs
are not easy to give up but it's a kind
of a black or white thing for me and
this is not necessarily for everyone but
for me
i am an addictive person so i have to be
all or nothing i'm either using drugs
and
very quickly heading to death or i'm not
and i'm very quickly heading to a
healthier happier life you can't dabble
at all you're a zero or one that's just
your dna no i don't have a glass of wine
on new year's or anything like that the
the the problem with stuff like heroin
is and it's not super
widely widely talked about it's like the
thing that i liked about it was it
actually changed my brain chemistry
right so whatever um
sense of happiness you get from
uh succeeding at a goal you set for
yourself
or or anything right is now being
given to you by this drug so when you
stop taking it your body doesn't know
how to do that so i was
you you have these ex junkies who are
perpetually depressed for years it takes
a long time for your body to get back to
normal it's not just like
get it out of your system and you're
fine right you're constantly thinking my
happiness whether it's uh
subliminal or or or or
you know you might not be having these
these thoughts analytically but
the the sense is like i cannot function
like a normal person without this stuff
because
your body doesn't react any longer like
a normal person so it takes a long time
to build those systems back up
the difference with food is
you can't be black or white you cannot
just quit eating you have to eat or
you're gonna die right so it's actually
way more complicated it's a lifetime
uh process there is no goal that i get
to this weight and i'm done that does
not exist for me with food
and
while i i want to think about drug use
also as a lifetime process it gets to be
so as long as you're not doing it you
know i'm not my wife drinks alcohol i am
never tempted to have a glass of wine
with her ever
i wouldn't go sit in a bar by myself i
wouldn't do that i'm not going
back to some dude's hotel room to watch
him do cocaine that's not something i
would ever put myself in that situation
right but i have to eat and so every
night while i'm eating and i'm
regulating what i'm eating there is that
thing that's you know under the surface
of like put more oil on it put more
sugar on it you know
double your portion so that's a that's a
more difficult thing i think to deal
with long term have you have you gotten
it to a point where food is now just
it's not you know like yesterday we were
eating with david berlinski i take him
to casa de angelo and i'm like uh so
what's your favorite food i eat the same
thing every day that can't be no i eat
the same thing every day what do you eat
for breakfast two egg whites two egg
whites and and sometimes so what do you
eat for lunch i eat uh you know
protein whatever and i would eat for a a
dinner burger every hamburger i said
every day he says i care less what he
ate i don't know we're at the nicest
italian restaurant what do you want i
don't know octopus i've never had it
before you've never had you're 80 years
old he lives in paris yeah he said no
don't need anything so so has food for
you because one connection some people
make that that i it's i think it's very
interesting you know i'm a foodie oh you
know oh my god we gotta go eat some
sushi we gotta go some and he mentions
like yeah food is not one
my method of entertainment food is not
no longer for me like i'm looking
forward to it it's just what my body
needs to eat and it's become very
regimented is that the distinction you
had to make that's what i try to do now
listen i too
love to eat and i think that as i got
healthier and tried to take more
responsibility with how i interact with
food i became way more interested in
very specific types of food like i flew
to um
china once to eat peking duck at this
little uh luquan roast duck it's in an
alley and it's like the best peking duck
on earth apparently like i've done stuff
just like i went to china for that to
eat come on i got the duck i'm out yeah
you know and then i i also ate you know
skewered scorpions that were fried on
the street and stuff like that like i'm
interested in food in that way
but
it there's i'm you know the thing i've
the thing i've also found is i i do eat
mostly the same stuff right
all the time i always have whey protein
and water for breakfast that is what i
eat for breakfast every day and water
and water not milk although i will say
there's this new um
fair life protein drink that's 30 grams
of protein and i think it is made with
well milk and i believe whey protein
comes from milk so there's that but i
don't put almond milk or anything like
that in my protein with my protein
powder um
you know moderation i think is the key
to winning for the rest of my life so i
don't want to cut off everything and say
you know if i'm in rome i'm not going to
eat the pasta dish that i love right i
can't do that but i'm going to have that
one time
and then the rest of the time that i'm
in rome i'm going to eat the way i eat
normally which is fish or meat and
vegetables
what's the most part what's your
favorite food like if you were to say my
favorite favorite food is like i would
say it's horme sabzi it's the persian
stew what's your favorite food i mean if
i was going to say my favorite iranian
food i would say tadiq oh and i would
want something really juicy to pour on
it you know what i mean never been to
rafi's place
is that in glendale yeah yeah yeah the
owner is my best man at my wedding
really yeah it's great food yeah
phenomenal food yeah the best yeah so
what's your favorite though what's your
favorite food my favorite is tied up
somehow with this uh memory of when i
was five and i showed up at my
grandparents house in vermont and they
said god you're so fat you're going on a
diet and then my grandfather cooked what
i remembered being my favorite meal
which was lasagna and they gave me
they said you get this
paper thin and so for the rest of my
life i was like that's my favorite i
don't think it really is
at five years old because i've read this
before that you're uh that it's kind of
triggered where you're at with all your
weight loss i don't always i don't want
to blame them i just i don't think they
i don't think they really
you know their intentions were good and
clean
but you know also honestly if they were
the same age today
and looked at the landscape of childhood
obesity they would have been like you
are fine
how how heavy i was at five i was a
chubby five-year-old i wasn't
an obese five-year-old but they were
shocked at my appearance and put me on
this crazy diet and then convinced my
parents to put me on diets for the rest
of my adolescence i i would say my
favorite food the food that i've eaten
the most
in the past 10 years is lebanese
lebanese is my favorite food lebanese
it's very clean you can get a healthy
meal it's not got a bunch of other
garbage in it
i saw the the three-hour podcast you did
with rogan yeah and the first hour you
guys just went in on food and dishes and
this and and pat just literally had how
many dinners did you have with rogan
this past weekend we were together for
uh friday night and saturday night till
like four o'clock in the morning steak
dinners though
cal ford steakhouse oh my and we ate
like at three in the morning so imagine
eating a fat steak at three o'clock like
that's not that's the worst thing you
can do we went to sleep yeah
yeah
yeah but you you guys went off about how
he said i could just eat steak
and vegetables and that's it i'm good to
go yeah but pasta like we had pasta and
steak last night
well yeah but see there's even there's a
there's a universe now that the the
landscape of diets and diet fads gets
really crazy so for
a long time i was convinced if i just
don't eat carbs i'll lose weight and
i'll be fine but it got to the point
where because i can overeat and and that
is really my predilection is to over
consume
i'll overeat steaks i'll eat 5 000
calories in a steak and only burn 3 000
calories that day and actually gain
weight so that's not
that's not a good um
solution for me so is it more important
to
portion control or eat healthier for me
okay there could be a guy who's out
there who won't eat thousand calories in
steaks and all he has to do is cut carbs
out of his diet and he'll be fine that's
possible you see this kid over here on
your left that guy carb loads right like
he's like
he eats a sandwich with the bread as the
as the meat and then more bread i'm like
what are you doing he gets the club
sandwich and removes the turkey exactly
yeah
talk some sense in the house
when you're 23 years old that works when
you're 33 you're gonna be a fat ass so i
gotta enjoy it while i can unbelievable
you gotta enjoy it
that's true right now so so go back go
back to you we were saying like the
motive because i feel like
you said something i had a friend of
mine and by the way we had kevin farley
here last week chris farley's brother
and obviously we know what happened with
chris he was also heroin and they try to
get to them over and over and over again
and then they eventually couldn't 33
years old boom it's done and we lost one
the greatest uh of all time but what was
because i had a friend that went through
it and we talked about it with kevin and
his deal was vicod and he couldn't give
it up but he was taking 25 to 50 a day
it wasn't like he was taking one or two
he's taken 25 i've seen him take 10 like
this and just put in his mouth like it's
candy right he was doing that uh and he
couldn't go without it he was addicted
to we took him to a tarzana
rehabilitation said you know which one
there's a tarzana rehab center and uh he
will have to go through for two weeks he
came out he was good boom a week later
he's reading the bible relapse done and
we get the phone call and uh
my best friend in the world anyway so
but but the point is i kept trying to
get his motive and it has to be him
so so he was
he was marrying a girl
that he loved i'm like do you love is
the love that strong that you're willing
to change for her i don't know if it was
you know he had reasons with his dad and
his mom he had a bro you know i'm like
maybe career maybe identity maybe it's
what what like we took him to church to
see maybe churches because you know a
lot of times it's church a lot of people
have given up a lot of drugs and alcohol
because of a
connection they had spiritual connection
to catholics mormonism scientology
christian
it doesn't matter there's so many great
stories even scientology has that one
place in the in uh uh what do you call
it the arrowhead i think it's arrowhead
right like uh where there's a facility
there that you're going through
drugs or rehab that you go through and
it's actually very effective i've heard
it from a lot of different people that
it's worked for them but there has to be
something on the individual right nobody
can impose you say you better get it
done what's the matter with you're going
to kill yourself that's not going to
work what what was your
so i you know it's hard to say because
in this conversation
you have people who are listening who
are going like i know a guy who i need
that guy to have whatever i had and i
just don't know if there's a formula to
create that in an individual i think
it's possible to present
data and solutions and like when you're
ready we're here you know i i've got
i've got a plan that you can follow but
i i do believe until the individual is
ready themselves
i had multiple interventions run on me
nothing i i
would go to sleep at night for for a
couple of years believing i was gonna
die in my sleep and was just like well
that's what it is and
none of that changed and i woke up one
day and was just
i i i was in need of change i i woke up
and i could not exist the way i was
existing anymore and i'm so thankful
that i didn't die before that day
happened and then likewise
food and and that health and my weight
was another thing that like no matter
what evidence people presented to me and
what solutions were presented to me i i
didn't change until i was ready to
change having been
a drug addict and
morbidly obese i've had many parents say
we need help with our kid and this and
that and and there was a period in time
where i would go and talk to people and
talk at schools and stuff like that and
here and and i'm happy to talk and share
my experience but sitting down with
one-on-one and and trying to convince
them
to change
that i've always had failures with i
just and i've always seen failures with
this i don't know
that it's possible to convince somebody
to change until they're ready to change
now that's not to say somebody comes and
says i'm ready to change and you go
great i can help you right that's
possible but i i have not seen
a lot of success with like we need to we
need to handle this guy we need to fix
it i totally agree with you know what
i'm not asking that what i mean what it
was exactly yeah you know what i'm
asking is like if you so for me what
i've seen is it's a girl you're in love
with a girl that
changes right it's a
loss of a loved one you lose a parent
you lose somebody you're like dude i got
there's or like for me my biggest like
how i changed dude if you would if you
had asked my
my counselor in high school said i feel
sorry for your dad having heart attacks
but i would also have heart attacks if i
had a son like you
in high school
there is there's not a single soul that
said i was going to amount to anything
in life right so i'm not the guy that's
supposed to win so the only guy that
said listen you're not a guy that's
going to do anything with your life why
don't you go join the army guy jesus
girl like he was a recruiting station
down from glendale high school because i
went to glendale high school so he was
right off of colorado and verdugo jesus
said hey pat i think you need to join
the army you got a uniform you got
something to do you're going to travel
they're going to pay for it you're going
to be able to get the hell out of here
i'm like oh that's the selling point to
me the selling point was you can get the
hell out of here and just go and i'm
like i'm in right i went in
then i got out and i'm still you know
i'm
you know determined to make money i got
dreams i want to do stuff i'm a
performer i'm not like a guy that's
sitting around not doing [ __ ] but
my dad had the heart attack i went to
the hospital i saw my dad on his
deathbed he lost 40 pounds and they
kicked me out of the hospital because
they were not treating him good and the
lady's like who are you who do you think
you are you this is a government you're
not paying taxpayers are paying for this
did you pay for this i'm sorry you can't
talk to us like that they came and they
kicked me out of the place i'm in in the
car my four four kiss i'm crying like a
little baby and it's as if like this the
next time i'm a whole different human
being i came to work and it was done i
went working 80 to 1 i said i'm not
going to stop till that guy doesn't have
to worry about a single thing about
money and it was game over
it's a 180 human being one minute to the
next minute my friends would call and
we'd go out and say we missed the old
pattern i said dude i don't miss the old
pet i like the new pat so you can
reminisce about the old pad that guy
ain't coming back i'm committed to this
but it was a moment with my father and
i've seen this happen with a lot of
people in my life i'm 43 right now
you're 1976 may 25th or may 26th you're
25 25 so yeah so i'm 43 so you see at 43
you see different things on what causes
people to change what was yours
for for
and i and i probably don't make it long
term with the drugs without my wife also
like in fairness but it
the the biggest change i saw was
me getting a taste of what my life could
be like with my wife who's now my wife
she wasn't my wife then and wanting it
to be better
and that was it that was all it took for
me to go like oh i'm never i'm never
turning back yeah so how long have you
been with her
20 years it's important you were you i'm
just sorry
you're way bigger when you met her yeah
i met her when i was 16. fell in love
with her when i was 16
was in the friend zone for a long time
and finally we started to have a
relationship and it was like the moment
we started to have a relationship i went
oh my god
i want to make sure this lasts how do i
make sure this lasts what's the what's
the thing i can do to be the best
partner to her i can possibly be and
that was the biggest change i could make
so it seems like it was and uh once that
like the kind of connection really
happened boom like almost like pat's
story with his dad
you i feel bad relaying that because i
can't
lend people my wife to inspire them you
know what i mean like oh that's but but
that's not but that's not how i process
it bro the way i process it is
is um
you know this the same goes the other
way like you know a transparent terry
there's a video that's going viral with
chats and kevin hart posted it and it's
a sick video he said and i shared it on
instagram today he said you know in life
you know you can
you can try so hard if you're a winner
to get your friends to win you can't do
it you can do it come on
he says you can put all your energy if
that guy doesn't want to do it you can't
do [ __ ] for that guy he said however
however
he said a great person trying to lift
somebody that has no desire won't work
he said however
a person with potential who has the
potential a bad person
can definitely demotivate you and pull
you down to their level that is
effective with everybody right so crabs
in a bucket but but the point is
i think
you know finding the right person that
you say i'm gonna do it for this person
or finding a motivation
that's gonna be for that person there is
a message there there is a message to
you know saying you know i'm gonna do it
for this person sometimes some
personalities we are more like you know
how there's guys that like to fight and
then there's guys that like to stop
fights you know there's guys that are
like hey what'd you say come on let's go
listen and then there's guys like i'm
sorry did you touch my friend you
touched my friend are you out of your
you you hit him and then boom you're
fighting for somebody right the flag
carrier mentality
of people if they have that they need to
have something
to fight for themselves i don't know if
that makes sense no it does totally and
i like what you said about having a
church having a support group finding a
group of people that are like-minded so
if you
if you are alone if you are struggling
with
getting motivated i think there are
groups out there that you can go and
become a member even if it's just a gym
and you're like i'm saying hi to that
dude every day and that's who i'm going
to be accountable i don't know their
names
i don't know anything yeah i want to see
i want to make contact with that person
say hello and we're both gonna nod and
we're gonna know we're doing this
together to some degree right i do agree
i don't think we're you know no man is
an island there's a beautiful poem no
man is an island and basically it's like
no matter and i believe in individualism
i am an individualist for sure but that
said none of us function on our own
we're all connected to other people and
there's a
symbiotic relationship that we have with
other people no matter what that's how
we are succeeding and surviving and all
of that yeah let me add one thing about
chaz you kid no i'm good um you're
choking up it's water um
so for you your motivation was your dad
right for you your motivation was your
wife or the chemistry that you had with
wife and you didn't want to lose that
feeling
it might for for me it's not always
someone else it sometimes comes down to
what's going on internally so for me
chas in the movie the bronx tale and i i
still like the fact that i met chaz and
was on the podcast it was the most
surreal moment and he gave me the card
and on the frickin card it had the quote
that i would write every single [ __ ]
day
for years and it would say
the saddest thing in life is wasted
talent so for me
it was more internal like my fear of
mediocrity i did not want to be average
i knew that i had gifts whether that was
with
business or sports or what i used to do
stand-up comedy or like
whatever i did like my biggest
motivation was like just don't be
average don't just be just a
run-of-the-mill
blah blah blah person so i no matter
what whatever it was that i ended up
being like
do it yeah so what like to people out
there find that motivation yeah and like
the the
coming full circle and the fact that you
brought up chaz
uh
i i love that guy i mean i still in my
wallet today is the card he gave me your
comfort i'm sorry the saddest thing in
life is i watch this show have you seen
this show have you seen the chad's shoes
i watched his show because you know
bronx tale started off as a broadway
show right and then it became a movie
and i think bob saw de niro saw it and
it's like hey what about if we do this
and i play the fi your father and you
play you know sunny and i saw him to
play for chas i'm not even kidding with
you
he does the entire movie beginning to
the end every line and he acts
everybody in the movie with one share
if you've never i went to uh somewhere
in full audited by los solos to watch it
was like a thousand twelve hundred
people in the room
i see you know how you know they say you
touch your phone 150 times a minute or
whatever the number is
i didn't touch my phone once for 90
minutes right
and i sat there i'm like i cannot
believe i didn't touch my phone it was a
re
the performance was insane you felt like
you were in the streets with him so
chance chad's props to him for what he's
doing yeah but uh respect man for where
you're at you know for for some that no
can you can you put up a picture of
uh uh by the way does it bother you when
you see pictures of before and after
doesn't know anything okay put pictures
of ethan
um
when just just just go images just go to
images there's one picture up there that
doesn't bother me at all
okay that's stud right there
the hot picture with you with your shirt
off so flexing well there's one there's
one that's pretty good there's other
ones i don't know legs
damn what picture are you most proud of
and what are you most ashamed i don't
want to say ashamed but i i never want
to go back to that i'm not really
ashamed it's just such a bizarre uh time
in my life that i that i just
really uh didn't care about myself at
all you know
is that the same human being
yeah look at that technically i mean
there's parts of my brain that haven't
regenerated you know because the skin is
louis elastic
yeah right what a character in that
movie what a freaking he made it by the
way i mean that that
every team needs a guy like that he's a
unifier
you play the role of a unifier in that
movie favorite movie you've ever done
you've done a lot what's your favorite
one that you've done that you're you're
both
most proud of as well as you had the
most fun
well
the the most fun is is a tricky one but
the one i'm most proud of for sure as
far as like a movie there's
you know wolf of wall street is is
really great but also cold mountain i
thought was like a really really great
movie um the most fun i had was either
wolf of wall street or a movie called
without a paddle which was because
without a pet oh my god i forgot
ah what was it was it what song was it
but my body is that the one but yeah i
don't see nothing wrong about the
is that the movie where they're called
oh my god it's a hell of a larry's not a
paddle what was that oh it's a hilarious
movie me and abraham ben ruby played
brothers and
and we're chasing these three dudes
around the forest
seth green yeah it was awesome
i remember this movie yeah of course
hilarious movie by the way i haven't
seen when did this movie come out early
2000s that was almost 20 years ago 2004
there it is yeah and then and then uh
matthew this guy was taking over
hollywood and then gone i don't what
happened to matthew lillard i don't know
he was on a tv show um recently called
that i did a couple episodes of and i'm
blanking on what it's good girls he was
on good girls yeah but
that happens to actors too like we go
and do a tv show and if you're not
watching the tv show it's as though we
disappeared off the face of the earth
yeah that's that's true um we got to
talk about remember the titans why is
that so important to you i mean the
thing about that was
the team the chemistry the race
relations that it took place in the 60s
what year was this you know when the
whole blm thing was going on with the
protesting i tweeted out i said america
go watch this movie no literally she did
i said go watch this movie today
everybody this movie needs to go viral
and everybody needs to watch it two
years ago it was two years ago yeah
because
the the story it was so much about what
was going on two years ago you know this
whole thing that you know hey you're
wide you're blocking buses no no you
guys are all mixing up you're all going
to sitting together and he takes him and
says hey look what happened to these
soldiers they fought together nobody
cared if you're white and black and then
they came back
and to them racism was gone but they
came to a group of people that racism
still existed and then they're kind of
like oh [ __ ] this is going to be kind of
awkward and that's kind of what's going
on right you're kind of like dude
i don't even think about race i don't
even think about the fact that we have
any different i'm freaking from iran
believe me when 9 11 happened and
everyone's looking i'm in the financial
industry where are you from i'm from
iran did you say you're i was born and
raised in iran you're born and raised in
iran yes
so you're from the same negative was
that that guy that did what he did yeah
kind of but but i'm different very much
kind of you know right he's like
thousand miles away
yeah yeah to the idiots out there you're
just a brown guy from the middle east
yeah but to the average guy like wow you
kind of look weird you don't look like
normal like us you know you look like
one of these but about as close as an
italian but that's close to an italian
i'm 18 attack because you did that test
and you're not french i did the test i
found out someone hooked up with an
italian 18
but everything else was pretty accurate
but you know you you see that movie and
you're like oh man dude we are so like
and i feel like it goes back to the same
thing they keep saying it over and over
and over and over and over they're
telling it to you so many times that
like you know naive people are buying
into it like you know what i think i am
no you're not no no no you're not
they've just convinced you you are you
are not that's not your dna that's not
your identity you don't wake up being
like that
it's just been sold to you constantly
right and then eventually like the whole
i read a book years ago it's called the
genius in all of us
and the author talks about how a
low income to middle income family a kid
who was born by the time he turns eight
uh 18 he has heard the word no or been
rejected 600 more times than he's been
encouraged right so a low income
middle-income family you've been
rejected 600 more times than encouraged
right you're you're you're now
accustomed to that you're now customers
yeah and then it says like middle to
lower upper upper class it was like a
hundred thousand that you've been
discouraged then encouraged and then it
explains families at upper and above
you're encouraged a hundred more
thousand times
than discouraged like it's above and
it's like the kids you know walking
around like this they have some
confidence they go to the schools they
feel pretty good about them so now this
is not for everybody because some of
them are very very critical but the
point is
words have power yeah affirmations a lot
of power and we're we're affirming by
the way i mean i don't even know where
you stand you know what do you think
about what's going on with america last
couple years here politically where
you're in an industry that's
you you you guys i have friends in that
world and we talk but you know it's
walking on x shows a little bit in the
business you're in how has that affected
your business the last few years how's
it affected my business well i you know
i personally um
find all politicians to be liars
and so i don't i i there's no way for me
to get behind a political party simply
because i just don't trust any of them
um
in in my business i do know
that
ten years ago tennis years ago there was
a group called the friends of abe
abraham lincoln being the first uh
republican president
and
it was a very big group and they would
publish their their board and all the
members and it was a very open group and
as soon as trump came into office the
other side
got so crazy that this group was no
longer allowed to exist so it disbanded
and uh and and that to me
that makes me sad the the intolerance
for another perspective because i think
that for the most part individuals not
politicians but individuals have these
ideas of i perceive a problem and for
the most part everybody can agree that
whatever x is a problem so then it's
just about finding solutions and i might
have a different idea about a solution
than you have but i don't think that we
should be
waging war with each other over our
difference
of solving the same problem and
and that intolerance is is very
disappointing i used to go to meetings
with john voigt in la and
uh with a
man named fred and then a couple other
guys
owners of public storage and would go to
this the house in malibu and they would
have the most interesting conversations
but the way they would do it it wasn't
like the republicans
they would bring the campaign manager of
bill clinton and they would bring the
campaign manager of bush
two-hour conversations 40 of us in the
room and let me tell you
unfreaking believably entertaining yeah
and like you're learning right so when
the camera was off they they got along
it's it's almost like hey we're just the
two different teams let's just figure
out you know what my motives are you
know and i got to give up some stuff to
get with you but
you know going through john and you know
some of the other guys i mean obviously
we know who in hollywood is what side
and what not side but
some of them got ousted some of them
didn't some of them were bulletproof you
couldn't do [ __ ] to clint eastwood it's
like no you can't yeah yeah you can't do
[ __ ] stuff
yeah for sure there are a couple of them
gary sinise i think he can probably
be aligned with whatever he wants and
he's fine but i think for the rank and
file there became a thing where it's
like well we're just not going to say
anything we're not going to openly
support anything
i agree yeah i agree that sucks and
and is there anybody that's kind of like
because i saw did you see the article
with mark wahlberg what he announced
yesterday if you want to pull up mark
wahlberg uh the movie he did did the
father stew with mel gibson
and mel give someone the greatest actors
of all time but he came out and he said
something yesterday about the fact that
he's inspired yeah said mark walter
explains how mel gibson inspired him to
spend millions and millions of his own
money on father stew
and not only that this story goes
further he says
i feel at this phase of my life i'm i'm
getting a calling can you make is this
yesterday's article or two days ago this
is two days ago oh it's it's uh it's
yesterday the article i wrote was
yesterday it's very recent go back a
little bit anyway so he himself
you see him as a pretty reasonable guy
reveals mark by the way
mark wahlberg
you can click on that one
really you can't really see it it's not
so overt but that dude has evolved that
dude when i was young i i've known
mark for a long time i did a movie was
he any american history x or no no but i
did a movie with him called deepwater
horizon but i have known him for a long
time when we were kids like children
teenagers he was a bit of a mess he
wasn't maybe as much of a mess or as
overt of a mess as i was and and i i
don't think he had a real drug problem
but or did drugs at all i don't i don't
know about that but
he now
is a father he's married he's very
serious about his faith like he has
turned his life around really in a big
way a big way and he you know the movie
he did bro was it brothers what was the
name of the movie where the four brother
the
it's him yeah
is it four brothers a movie yeah exactly
yeah so i and tyrese i just say i just
feel like yeah that's him
the movie he played the story of mickey
not mickey ward is it mickey word where
the brother is a is it the fighter he's
called the fighter
you just look at him you're like i don't
think you're acting bro i just believe
you you know i just think you're being
you like denzel's not acting to me
denzel is just himself you know and he's
got one role that he crushes it right
you don't see him being able to do
you know but he sticks to this one role
that he crushes because i don't think
he's acting but to see a guy like him uh
he just showed me an article here from
people magazine where he says uh uh you
know he's
feeling like there's a calling
this is god choosing me it was one of
the yeah god choosing me
tyler it's on slack it's i don't see it
on slack check yesterday anyway so
you're seeing you're seeing some of that
taking place because
i believe uh uh the power of right there
so mark wahlberg says he spent millions
on faith-based movies this is god
choosing me to make it okay go up a
little bit to see what else he says
they're making a little bit bigger uh 50
year old angel manager right now sorry
german father still male gibson was
every director or something several
million let's just say i put millions
and millions of dollars into the film
and then incurring
other costs because we went over
schedule and production and there were
clearances for the music
uh uh
said well we're adding that the few
friends who believed in the project also
invested in walmart said he prayed every
day about getting this film made i
cannot take credit for the movie success
because this is god choosing me to make
this film he knows finally i get to
utilize all the talents and gifts that
have been bestowed upon me for his
greater good and serve
my part in his big picture so
you're seeing some of that this is i
believe you know you know
one time
one of my mentors dudley gives a speech
he said there's seven mountains to climb
you know
military you know you got business you
got church you got all these politics
and then he says entertainment he says
the toughest one to climb to the top is
entertainment but entertainment is the
one that you can really have some mass
influence right whoever controls
hollywood and movies controls the masses
i mean that's just what there is to it
if i want to manipulate a mindset into
anybody i'll just make a movie out of it
and put the right actor spend 100
million dollars i can get you to think
well maybe that's not that bad of an
idea right
so but i don't think we have enough
competition on both sides like i think
vince vaughn was it where he went and he
sponsored he endorsed was it ron paul at
a libertarian event i don't know if you
remember that i don't know but i do know
that that whatever he did politically
probably had sort of an effect on him
yeah so you think hollywood kind of
excommunicated him because he i don't
know i don't know about ex-communicator
he's still around he's still doing
movies but vin vaughn was a massive
movie star dude and meg was not a
massive movie
and i don't think he had a huge string
of failures no i what failure i mean i
do the guy has got everybody gets their
set of failures like you talked about
earlier before our show goes we
literally disappear uh but
but what what what what does it take in
that space
to get to a point of being untouchable
is it your own money because clint is
using his own money at this point of
course he's got some investors that come
in as well but it's majority of it is
his own money
also even think about this woody allen
woody allen still makes a movie every
year or every other year or something
like that and he is basically
in dark blacked out like you don't hear
about the movies you don't see the
movies they're all just going to europe
or something like that but he still
manages to get them made it's it's all
funded out of another country or private
private investors or something like that
hollywood is not investing in woody
allen i don't know if there's anybody
that's
untouchable in hollywood no matt i mean
look at will smith i mean he would have
been a martial
harvey weinstein i mean but he's not he
doesn't have the name recognition that a
will smith does or even a mel gibson did
in the early 2000's there's a difference
harvey weinstein was a gangster he was
yes he was politically connected harvey
weinstein was behind the scenes yeah
untouchable but to the masses it's like
who's this
there's there there is a there is an
example there that's different than
vince vaughn and then clint and he got
some of the other guys right grump you
know josh
i would put him there as well probably
if uh uh is it frank uh
is it chris chris pratt chris pratt
right who played uh they're trying to
they're trying to get him too yeah
they're trying to get him to to get rid
of chris brack because he's religious
zach levi even zach levi who's they
though
uh there's a big portion of
hollywood or the left which
does not approve of the church that
chris pratt goes to and so there is
constantly attempts to say like
you should not have until this guy
apologizes for his church or makes his
church better you should
not hire this guy are these the same
people that are trying to cancel if you
were part of the friends of abe or are
they the same people that are trying to
cancel pratt are they saying you know by
the way canceling vince vaughn who are
these people it could be two people on
twitter
i don't know who who it is but there is
a general sentiment
that uh if your church was ever not
super fond of gay people your church is
excommunicated and you can't be a part
of it so i know like ellen page has uh
elliot page has come out and talked
poorly about chris pratt and his church
which then leads to voices on twitter
anonymous voice comments on twitter yeah
and
and it builds that way i don't know who
all of the people are but they're
the the culture of hollywood is very
um get in line or get out yeah i mean
not not tolerant of religious positions
not
tolerances irony there that their whole
thing is inclusion
uh
tolerance but if you don't fit in fall
in line
i think any of that though even on the
right if it's if the idea is like
absolute free speech
then you know
what was the um
the satanic panic of the 80s and 90s
that was all a right-wing fear of like
you can't talk about this stuff right
like let's arrest two live crew their
language is bad i think no matter what
the group in power wants to stay in
power and they want a homogeneous uh
dialogue so that there's no dissent
there's no taking that power away from
them yeah don't don't forget we're not
against rap we're not against rappers
but we are against those thoughts thugs
right so they wanted to kind of you know
the hip-hop all of that
so but here's here's what you said you
said harvey weinstein and you said will
smith the difference with will smith
it's a self-inflicted he screwed up
holly was not canceling him he canceled
himself that's what he did that's a big
scroll which we can talk about that but
will smith
is a screw-up which is a lot deeper than
anything else but by the way
my preference would be
you do something that people are
offended by you have a very clear path
to redemption there should be some way
to make amends you come out and
apologize i don't know what it is but
there should be a way to go like
without being self-serving i screwed up
i'm really sorry that's not me because
will smith to me is like he was the he
was this i still think he's a sweetheart
and he had a bad one
but think about what we're saying here
right now we're actually putting harvey
freaking weinstein and will smith even
no no he's not i don't know i'm not
saying that i'm just saying the fact
that those two names are intertwined
because will smith slap chris rock i
don't think they're in the same country
no no they're not that's my point yeah
but the fact that
harvey weinstein what he did was
disgusting and repugnant
and what will smith okay
can i make a can i make a
prediction i'm gonna make a prediction
to you okay
so
what what i think is happening is the
following so will is different story
harvey said that harvey is you know
complete he uses power to abuse and all
that stuff and eventually it was too
late
vince is hey we don't agree with you he
is actually being affected by because
this guy goes from being one you saw him
everywhere to and by the way that guy's
multi-dimensional he did like this one
psycho movie that you know maybe it was
psycho i don't know what movie he was in
where he's playing this freaking crazy
husband that's capable of doing murder
and all these things and he goes and
does wedding crashers so he's so
multi-talented right but uh
you know the clinton of the world all
these guys here's what's about to happen
and you're going to see how this whole
thing's going to come together
so elon musk goes out there and says
hey i got a problem with what's going on
with twitter all of a sudden i'm
convinced he's like oh you guys want to
silence uh the president you want
silence rogan you want to silence this
you want sinus babylon you want to oh
you do no problem okay cool here's what
i'm going to do
i'm going to buy twitter no no no no no
i love it he just wants so happy he just
wants to be a minority shareholder
oh no he's buying 9.2 percent matching
morgan stanley as the biggest
shareholder and then the ceo of twitter
sends a tweet saying well we're working
together we're welcoming him to be on
the board
and then he's like dude i'm not joining
the board and then the ceo of twitter
digs
at uh ilana a little bit and i'm
convinced elon's like i'm sorry what did
you just say
i own this company bro
i'm the biggest shareholder no problem
you know what if we can show this
article here yahoo find this morning
elon musk offers to buy 100
of twitter for fifty four dollars a
share i can't wait to enjoy it dude can
you imagine
yeah
i can't wait
so
he goes up there and buys it this is a
byproduct of boolean
this is a byproduct of bullying so what
am i convinced going to happen next
here's what i'm convinced going to
happen next see the quote i invested in
twitter as i believe in its potential to
the platform free speech around
social imperative for functioning
democracy however since making my
investment now realize the company will
neither thrive nor serve the social so
societal imperative in its current form
twitter needs to be transformed as a
private company as a result i'm offering
to buy 100
by the way do you think morgan's
family's not going to sell to them
morgan doesn't give a [ __ ] he was like
dude take the money the market's about
to tank next year buy it they're making
40 of their money there dude that's
crazy right so they're they're calling
it a 43 billion dollar hostile takeover
why is it considered to have taken cause
the board does not want him yeah let let
it be a hostile takeover it's great but
here's the thing guys brace for impact
brace for freaking impact who did bezos
just buy recently washington post no no
he bought that away from gmc
studios recently now
the motor really yeah he did he just
bought him that's crazy i didn't know
that so so so you got these two guys
okay buying everything
wait a minute but but do you see bezos
as a true believer or do you believe
bezos is playing a game of who's gonna
end up having the most money in the most
power and and do you think elon musk is
a true believer where which of these
guys is more concerned about the little
guy and protecting the voice
i don't think it's even a question i
agree with you right i totally agree
with you so here's the thing he's buying
for business i saw jon stewart interview
bob iger from disney
and questioning about news and abc and
all this stuff and you know you guys are
how you reported on this and you
reported on that and you guys are so on
one side and say i don't know about if
we're one side or so you don't think
you're once that it was a very
interesting interview if you haven't
watched it's 15 minutes highly recommend
you watch jon stewart interviewing igers
like two weeks ago especially with
what's going on with disney right now
with all that stuff
i think
i'm convinced
elon's gonna get into the movie business
i'm convinced this next move you got two
other companies you gotta buy okay the
next company he has to buy is cnn he has
to buy it okay because
he's more of a ted turner than the
current
cnn is a ted turner so he buys these
guys then he buys uh uh uh uh what do
you call it he buys cnn after buying cnn
he has to go buy a major catalog or a
major media company okay
no it's not netflix he could do hulu he
could do one of those other guys
he could do any of those guys and you
can buy that four package for him it's
not a big deal not a movie studio so
mgm so well mgm is gone because i'm
saying like a paramount that's what he's
gonna do he's gonna do that because he's
starting people have to realize okay the
way hitler got the world to buy into him
is the first time the movie titanic came
out who was the director of titanic a
guy named hitler and who was a hero of
titanic
hero of titanic at the end as a nazi the
soldier that saved was a nazi i didn't
see this version okay so let's if you go
to titanic not the leonardo dicaprio
first titanic what okay you guys are
okay go titanic 1943. okay go put
titanic 1943 film
okay
right there
okay
yes this is a german propaganda film
which was nazis were heroes wow and he
was controlling the entire movie
beginning to the end commissioned by
joseph goebbels yes that's the point so
so so what what am i are you no i'm just
gonna know about this i just desperately
hope you're not gonna compare you're a
must to hitler no
no no no no well you're you are saying
propaganda and winning hearts and minds
no i'm saying that's what they're doing
today right i'm saying that's what
hollywood's doing today
you guys and then churchill had to go
again these against you know freaking
hitler to
save the world or else all of us would
be speaking german i think a guy like
churchill and musk are very similar i
think musk is going to come out and
going to say you guys think you're that
bad no problem watch what we're going to
do and by the way you saw already
they're trying to get them for twitter
oh investigation sec [ __ ] [ __ ]
all that crap's going to come but what
makes elon musk similar to clint
eastwood it's his own money and he's got
this going for himself he tells
everybody go
screw yourself so i think
he's he's got it he's got it's like a
trinity trinity is what twitter okay
which is what we're talking cnn that's
where we get the news and he needs to he
needs the trinity it's the media movies
i think that happens whole
people
people are going to be shivering every
night saying holy [ __ ] and in hollywood
finally the vince mans of the world are
going to get their 20 million dollars
because that's a 20 million dollar movie
guy that's not a freaking 2 million
dollar guy that's a 20 million movie guy
and it's going to go back to saying
let's compete you know okay so that's my
prediction i may be way off but i
foresee something like that take it i
think if elon's got two more moves it's
two moves cnn i love him yeah he thinks
he thinks long term in terms of how he
set up with the roadster and he's a true
believer the tesla s and then the tesla
three so he thinks in five 10 15 year
increments so i mean if there's anyone
to think that long and that far out i
mean he's the guy i also love that he's
open to
like you know if you wanted to get some
feature added to a ford pickup truck
good luck
it would take 20 years or or you know
all kinds of st elon musk reads a tweet
thinks it's a good idea it's happening
the next day in a car you know what i
mean yeah it's unbelievable when he when
he first took over
9.2 on twitter he said does twitter need
an edit button and he spelled yes wrong
to kind of
okay let me i don't i don't want to be
the dissenter here
but let me just kind of throw this out
there is there
we're kind of singing elon musk's
praises and all the great stuff that
he's doing you're talking the trinity
what's the downside with having that
much power as one guy there's got to be
something nothing as long as there's a
competitor nothing capitalism works i
trust it capitalism works because
there's competition
these [ __ ] i'm sorry i don't
use the f4 too often what they've done
is they've eliminated all their
competition is what they've done they've
had a monopoly hollywood's had a
monopoly for too long and behind closed
doors they're bullying people netflix
came and they freaking scared the [ __ ]
out of everybody where ricky gervais
gets up on stage and says what hey you
guys may as well give up and surrender
and say netflix take all the awards
tonight right netflix played a very
important role okay then you got hulu h
all of a sudden they're like wait a
minute wait a minute i used to have
control of all of you guys i don't
anymore it's called capitalism it's
called innovation it's called pushing
you back a little bit and and in every
industry
you're gonna experience bullies okay in
every industry you're gonna experience
bullies what happens with bullies is
bullies can only go so far but what
bullies don't realize is bullies inspire
people
and and bullies inspire those who go up
against bullies hitler was a bully
churchill is the guy that goes up
against bullies okay
i can't go on and on about people that
went up against bullies what bullies
bullies kind of you know
it's very easy if you allow somebody to
bully you every day the next day the
next day the next day what are they
going to do they're going to keep taking
your lunch until you finally stand up to
them right
what's starting to happen today is guys
like elon there's going to be more
that's not just ilan by the way there's
a few other guys peter thiel's on that
camp and there's a few there's like 50
guys
that are brawlers
that if you and what they've done is
some of them were asleep
some of them were
distracted but they officially have
woken up some of the guys that they
should have never woken up and they're
true believers they're about to
experience competition the next decade
or two like they've never experienced
before i'm convinced the next two
decades are gonna be freaking sick by
the way i just want you to do a
motivational speech
you basically say that because i feel
better
you know what i mean like i feel like
we're gonna be okay they're gonna be
okay
i'm telling you right now i this whole
thing with futures bright i keep saying
futures bright futures
i'm telling you guys like musk are going
to get up because the next you know how
somebody's a president what do we do we
kind of want to emulate the president so
reagan's president oh
i'm going to talk like reagan because
reagan and johnny carson they kind of
talk like each other they have their
same style in it bill clinton oh [ __ ]
bill clinton's a player i'm gonna be a
player too doug you know
yeah
you know
obama here you know we're all walking on
so yeah so you know we're talking we're
doing all this stuff then trump's
president doug we're back i'm an
entrepreneur i'm a [ __ ] so
when an elan is now the hero
[Music]
you're gonna have
five million kids going to school
who are all in try out right now
who are the next future elons they can't
let an elon stay as a hero
they have to control who the hero is
because if elon stays as the hero dude
you're not only locked in next 10 20
years you may be locked in the next 40
years if he stays as the hero it's very
very important who is painted as the
hero for a decade or two because kids
emulate them like steph curry is a great
face of the league lebron's not he's a
horrible face of the league horrible
like i hope giannis becomes the face of
the league because the way he asked him
a question the other day so how much
does a scoring title mean to me nothing
i believe it's dangerous to chase things
like that i don't care about the scoring
title he sits out the last game joel
embiid wins the scoring title he could
have won the scoring title he gives
two shits about scoring title that's why
he's a good face right i think elon's a
good face and he's going to inspire the
next freaking sick people that are going
to come up to even better than elon did
so i'm convinced the next decade or two
is going to be solid i'm excited we're
going to do our fight we're going to do
our part because it's not going to be
like it's going to be people at
different levels that are going to be
fighting and those guys are going to
unite and then it's going to be like
okay okay mr bullies you guys good you
guys want to fight are you good i mean
it is very very fountain head like right
like he really is like howard roarke and
you see like if he winds up buying cnn
that would be crazy watch when it
happens that would be wow good watch i
wouldn't invest in cnn today
i invested in twitter when it crashed
did you see cnn plus his numbers bro yes
did you see the numbers
what what does that cost that's 300
million dollars wow they spent 300
million dollars and they got 10 000 to
the point where cnbc tweeted out calls
can you go to my twitter and just put
with cnbc they're like boys you're not
supposed to go on cnn but that's why you
trust capitalism go up keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going a little bit more it's it's
coming up here oh right there click on
that one right there that one right
there look at this
cnbc says fewer than 10 000 people are
using cnn plus on a daily basis two
weeks into its existence sources tell
cnbc casting doubt on the future the app
following the combination of discovery
warner media they're on the same page
so even people on the same page are
calling each other out because
capitalism freaking works and it said
since when does cnbc call out cnn this
is why i trust capitalism cnbc's ott
peacock is kicking cnn's ass peacock has
nine million paid customers and cnn only
has ten thousand it's that simple cnbc
is dominating cnn good for them so it's
ten thousand yeah that's something so
300 million you just got wallets you're
like oh we got wallace from fox news and
we're gonna have ten thousand dollars
do you think cnn's brand is tarnished
they need a good run irrevocably until
the right person is driving the company
at the top so you think that it comes
down to just a figurehead leadership bro
one million ted turner do you know what
ted turner did to media ted turner was
ted turn around to be a president
yeah elon musk could be president if he
was born here elon musk is the kind of
guy that could make the government
change the laws to allow 100 wonderful
office one day who's lived in america
for 35 years the elon musk could be the
reason why we may have an amendment to
say
anyone that's been a citizen of the
united states for 35 years can run for
office it would be really fun to watch
the leftists argue against this that's
great about not allowing foreigners to i
can't wait to hear that what are they
going to say
did you know what it is that's what
they're foreign
go there go there break that down well i
i mean i'm just saying
i just think any of these things right
any of these things are viewed through
the perspective of what i want so as
long as it aligns with what i want then
it's fine if uh you know today if you
ask the majority of people on the left
should foreigners be allowed to run for
president they would say hell yes i
assume but if it was elon musk who was
the foreigner they would say no
we only can have americans running for
you know what i mean i just think that
that's the way i'm going to pull up i'm
going to do paul right now on twitter
i'm going to do a quick these are my
assumptions but they're good assumptions
though it's good assumptions that uh
that you got there so can you can you
imagine can you imagine if that happened
can you imagine in in in the next six to
12 months elan owns twitter he owns cnn
and he owns a big ass freaking
production you know like like a mgm
oh dude just brace for impact the best
part about it is the following
you ever seen a bully cry when they lose
it's the best kind of cry
oh dude i mean you know there's
different levels to crying there's real
crime where you feel bad for the person
there's crying that's funny crying like
dude
yeah it's hilarious but the best kind
the greatest of the greatest crying yeah
is the bully crying dude it's like the
it's like in um
your boy
[Music]
denzel washington and what's the movie
uh yeah the the training day
got nothing on me i built this [ __ ] he
starts crying like that's the stuff
that's your boy but like everyone was
rooting against denzel washington the
entire movie and then finally the whole
hood turns against him yeah and the cry
and the sobbing and you don't
denzel is the man's man you don't expect
that from him but that's the cry
that everyone's like hell yeah or like
ivan drago and rocky yeah when he when
rocky knocked him out it's such a relief
to see right as a as an outsider it's
it's like oh freaking awesome right
everyone's talking about it uh when bill
burr bilber was on um
uh conan i love billboard and kona it's
my favorite combination of interviews i
like billboards double ginger i love
billboard i did a movie with him did you
yeah which one was it um walk of shame
we played cops me and bill burr were a
pair of cops chasing this girl is he the
same on camera as he is off camera like
is he that's just the guy pretty much
pretty much that's who he is yeah i can
listen to bill for hours i won't get
tired of it but but he says uh
he's sitting so uh were you following uh
conan asked the question were you
following the the election where you
finally says
yeah maybe a little bit you know i was
at the hospital my wife was giving birth
and we had to tv on and i'm watching
this guy you know say things and it says
so what do you think about the results
he says dude i gotta tell you
watching people on the other side cry
and lose their minds the great he says
kirk gibson forget about it u.s beating
you know whatever the hockey this is
great everything keeps going it's like
this was the greatest thing i've ever
seen the feeling of people that thought
this will never freaking happen
uh i i have a feeling right now elon in
the next 30 60 90 days is gonna get hit
up from every different angle girls are
gonna come out they're gonna get guys
are going to come out
you you're going to see character
assassination
at the highest level that's coming soon
yeah see there's me and don't we look
like cops me and bill
it's actually it's just the you throw a
mustache on you buddy you could do yeah
anything you want with that muscle oh
you were walking [ __ ] yeah i've that
dude
how many movies you've been in bro
quite a few movies quite a few movies um
i i do i do this i do feel like if if he
if he succeeds with twitter and if if
cnn catches wind of him trying to buy
them it is going to be a bloodbath with
their reporting on musk i love that
what's her name by the way that actress
dunst no no um chris she's a great i
think she's a christian i'm i'm blanking
on her name right now elizabeth banks oh
yeah wasn't she a 40 year old virgin
no i don't think yes she was that's
go go see if she was in a 40 year old
virgin type and yeah she wasn't 40. go
type in 40 year old virgin
do it the other way ron do 40 virgin and
then you'll see the cast because it's a
while back that's right she was in the
hunger games she played the uh the tell
the hostess she wasn't 40 or she did at
blockbusters remember when they're
so yes what's your name what's your name
yes
yes yes yes
it was that's
oh my god it's a great scene between the
two of them she did a great job yeah
that scene right there classic oh by the
way
steve carol do you know what that is
that is at the encino valley total
fitness used to have a borders right
there that's my sister was the manager
at the valley tour they shot it right
there at the encino valley tour fitness
character could have been based on your
sister
[Laughter]
shout out to paulette
working at the bookstore so uh with the
40 year old virgin
uh so going back to uh uh movies with
different guys you work with who
who did you see act and it's like
one take type of guy you're like how the
hell do you do just one freaking take
like who was the most ridiculous talent
you've seen and you know it's unfair to
ask this question because it's not like
one or two you work with the best of the
best
but who was somebody like when i talked
to guys you know i've interviewed some
of the guys and the mob movies some of
those guys everybody's like well let me
tell you marlon brando dude this guy was
like
something else right and he talked to
guys that are like the chris browns and
some of these guys ushers who have
worked and done something with michael
jackson back in the day stuart one time
discussed choreography
i'm less impressed by that being an
actor myself i expect people to come in
and do a good job what i'm really
impressed with is work ethic and and
showing up on time and knowing your
lines and just being prepared in those
ways and i will say i've been friends
with him for
25
or almost 30 years leonardo dicaprio and
i'd been to
on sets with him before i actually
worked with him and
i i never i just never paid attention to
this but working with him
he was always the first guy on set he
knew all his lines
he never missed a beat he so and and for
me you know that's not always the case
sometimes the star is the last guy on
set and you're all like on your marks
waiting for them to arrive and they walk
on and you start you know what i mean
there was that that did not occur with
him at all
does that set the tone for everyone it's
like if leo's here first and he's
working hard like everyone it really
does yeah when when you have guys who
are starting to come in later
if they're hungover if they're not
prepared if they're reading their sides
you know while they're standing on their
mark if they're holding it up a little
bit
it does it drags a little bit right
having a guy who's so gung-ho who
i've seen before where um they're
they're he's getting dressed while
walking to set just because
he doesn't want to hold anybody up so i
was very very impressed with him when i
worked with him have you ever
have you have you ever had scenes that
maybe you know wasn't recorded like you
know how christian bale
lost his mind on the audio guy whoever
was that's walking back it's one of the
best scenes by the way when you see him
lose it there's something
uh uh
it's like watching a chef lose it
there's something very
or bill o'reilly [ __ ] it we'll go alive
you know there's something very
creative madness you know it's it's cool
scientist type of thing in action has
that happened where you're on a set and
one of the main characters like there's
a slight little movement or adjustment
they just are so sensitive to everything
that they lose it i mean i've had i've
seen it before where um i don't want to
name names but a long time ago
15 years ago i did a
a movie for television you know they
used to do that like tv movies and um
one of the actors got into a fight with
a grip like a fist fight with a grip
over something like that and i i didn't
even know what exactly had happened or
if there was tension with these guys
before but suddenly they're fighting and
i was just like
what the [ __ ] is happening like
we're at work you can't be doing this
and uh and they got separated and then
it was fine but but i haven't seen
anything quite as wonderful as um
you know
those few instances you know also
when i started acting so almost 30 years
ago
we heard stories there was a very famous
and i don't really want to get super
graphic but there were stories about a
sylvester stallone recording because he
was miked and went back to his trailer
and something occurred and it got
recorded and i never heard the recording
so it could be just like an old wives
tale but that scared the [ __ ] out of me
so anytime there was a microphone
anywhere near me i was like
somebody's listening somebody's
recording this be careful now are you
still tight with leo yeah yeah he's a
very good when is leo going to settle
down or is he ever gonna settle down and
get married i don't know i have no idea
but by the way you know i i uh i had
i'm convinced of this i may be wrong but
i had dinner with a guy named david
herzog who was the ceo for aig
and he was there with bob and moshe
these are the guys that went and got 183
billion dollars from the government and
then they paid it back and gave 21
billion dollars this guy was a cfo so
he's like
very very powerful guy in the in the
financial industry
and i said so you know tell me about
yourself oh i've been married 27 years
oh okay cool how many kids you guys got
we don't have any kids really you know i
always give you guys you know any reason
no we just chose a long time ago our
kids was our career really both my wife
and i made our kids our career our kids
and that's how we treated it and both of
us have done very well we run a
restaurant and on a
golf course and she manages that and i
do what i do here like okay cool i think
certain people make their career their
wife or their kids and some actually
look at it that way do you think that's
what's happening with leo first of all
do you think he lacks options i mean if
you wanted to zero this is why we're so
like enthralled by what he's got going
on but i think i think the way he just
described leo makes sense to me why he
can't do that because to give that kind
of commitment
you you can't have distractions uh to to
you know that you anyways i'm i'm
speculating i'm not his friend he's his
friend but i'm just thinking certain
people that take it to that level i had
a guy talk to one time
and uh greg his name was this but this
is like 18 years ago i said if you were
to tell me
a few weird things that nobody talks
about that you want to make it all the
way to the top what would you suggest he
says never get married never have kids i
said what i said but you're married and
you have kids okay so i never made it to
the top i i will say having a wife and
kids
the absolute worst place to bring them
is to work it's it's the worst
distraction ever because if you're here
and you're consumed and you're and
you're trying to do your job to have
this
you know
a movie set is almost like being in a
construction zone you know what i mean
like nothing's ever fully built it's all
being presented from one direction and
there's stuff you can't touch and places
you can't go and you there's nowhere to
sit down sometimes and to have this idea
of like my wife and my kids the people
who i need to make sure they're okay all
the time
are taken care of
i've done tv shows where i've brought
kids in and gone like
you want to come you're a pa you have to
work if you're going to be here and we
can have lunch together and all that but
i can't think like what's my kid doing
right now where is where are they they
sitting in my trailer watching tv
or or i don't know what you know what i
mean it's it's a rough place to
to you really have to be concentrating
on what you're doing
respect man the uh the the the
legacy and and the stories of leo are
just
insane i mean it was first i think jeter
then clooney now leo is just the
freaking man as far as like has been the
man for a few decades though it's not
correct that's why people are you know
wondering what's next for this guy but
he's that dedicated to his crafts is
what you're saying so you think you
think
uh like for instance one of the things
that i'm enthralled about with pat is
like his work ethic but he's married and
he's got four kids and he's running two
businesses and he's dealing with all
this yet he still is the first one in
last one like that's
it it makes kind of like what you did
with leo makes you raise your standards
and say all right i can't slack off i
got the [ __ ] the boss over here doing
more than anyone i mean that's kind of
what you're saying with leo over there
do you think his worth worth work ethic
would be exactly the same if he was
married with kids and that would kind of
take away i think he would
compartmentalize because i think i have
a good work ethic i just think it's hard
like
to
merge the two so if you're if you're him
and and again
when you do when i did that movie with
him he worked every day i worked not
every day right i worked many fewer days
than him so i could bring my family and
make sure that i spent a lot of time
with them too on the days that i wasn't
working they just couldn't come to work
for him that's six months where he's
working every single day and then on the
weekend he's preparing for next week's
work and at night after work he's
preparing for tomorrow's work and so i
think it is
less conducive in that but i i think he
would be
capable certainly of compartmentalizing
these things
yeah and i would assume like if you're
like really lighting it up you're like
doing more movies and you're taking on
more things
once you have family and you decide to
go to the next round then you're a
little bit more picky and choosy on what
you take and what you don't take it
you're and he's already pretty picky and
choosy like he doesn't have
movies coming out back to back to back
to back
yeah
you you look at the list of do you put
him as a top 10 of all time i think he's
very good yeah who who do you have as
like if you were to say i think in you
know like nba michael you know
football brady who's yeah who you put in
your top five top ten i think daniel day
lewis is is really hard to beat as an
actor three times a three-time winner or
four-time one i don't even know i just
know that he disappears into these roles
and he's always compelling and i really
enjoy watching him um
meryl streep i like a lot
um i don't go really too much deeper
than that i just like those two i think
those two are great and i think leo's an
incredible actor too um
but he's my buddy so i don't want to i
don't want to think of him as that way
did you have someone that you kind of
emulated you said all right i can i see
what this guy's doing you know obviously
i want to be my own person and you know
all that stuff but it's like all right
cool like this guy's doing it i'm a
bigger guy but i've lost his weight who
do you try to emulate well
as of today i'm just trying to
almost figure out who i am now you know
i've i've
been losing weight for 15 years or
closer to 20 years
but like today i am certainly different
than what most people know me as right
when i was a kid
i didn't see him as a big guy but i
really looked at like
guys like peter laurie this old german
star and i just thought like what an
incredible career that guy had you know
he was in he was in so many different
things and played so many different
roles and he was always interesting and
he was like the consummate that guy
actor and and that's really the guy who
i was like if i could have a career like
that dude i would be so happy wasn't
there a documentary called that guy
probably yeah there was a documentary
could type in document peter glory no no
a documentary that guy
uh faces you know but you don't know the
name there's a documentary called
uh uh uh
who
go back go back and just that guy who
was in that thing yeah that guy who was
in that thing yeah that's a documentary
by the way you know that one
video that you see with jonah hill being
interviewed
and you know he's kind of losing his
school and he says so you know
how does it feel like
you're like that fat guy in hollywood
right you're like that fat guy in
hollywood's like can we ask next
question he said well i'm just asking
this because in hollywood you were the
fat guy now you're the skinny guy
but you're still the fat guy does that
help your courier and you can tell he's
getting irritated right now i think he
went to jimmy kimmel and jimmy kimmel's
like wow you actually smell very good
and he says why would you ask that
question i just didn't see you as
somebody that would smell very good why
not and
he's not being funny he's actually being
irritated he's like dude what are you
doing so
when you see him uh going through what
he's going through and you you've you
know you've recreated yourself
does that hurt the brand because
hey who's the best guy that we can get
that can play xyz it's jonah okay let's
get him who's the best guy oh gosh now
we gotta does it hurt the brand to
position the actor in a role that maybe
would have worked when he was not in
shape instead of being in shape type
casting essentially
does it hurt jonah's brand or did it
hurt my brand both of you i mean i i
don't think it i don't think it hurt
jonathan jonah is a very very funny
person he's very witty he's written a
lot of the stuff that he's done so
that's a whole other
universe from what i do i i don't do
that i don't create material for myself
which you know if i was capable of doing
that maybe i'd have a much better career
than i do i'm very happy with my career
but you know what i mean like jonah
hill's clearly on a much higher level
than i'm on
so i don't think it's hurt jonah's brand
at all um and if you see him now he's so
happy oh my god
his happy in his happiness infects me i
look at him and
i know there were there was a rough
package there right and and i think it's
i think and
and i don't know we haven't talked he's
a buddy of mine too we haven't talked
that specifically about this but it's
got he something has washed over him and
he has let go of something and he
doesn't give a [ __ ] anymore the media's
out there trying to you know the media
does [ __ ] where they try you know like
they did it to me too
um
now they're nice to him but there's a
minute where you lose weight and they
just want to criticize you and say like
you're not going to get work or here's
the downside look at his loose skin look
at all these negative stuff and they
were doing that to him a little bit and
he just said [ __ ] you i don't care and
and and
he radiates inner peace and happiness
now like it's it's marvelous
for me
yeah it's it's it's affected my career a
little bit i just had a movie out
you know um a couple weeks ago called
dog which i'm super happy i saw that
yeah congratulations thank you so it
hasn't kicked me out of hollywood at all
but
you know i also i also can look at my my
movie career prior to doing television
and going like well doing television
might have affected my movie career you
know what i mean and i lost a sizable
amount of weight at that point
doing television
is it is it a different
it okay so what's what's what's a
promotion in your world is it
uh feature or is it having a television
show that stays for three four five six
years what's well i'll just put it to
you this way the most money i ever got
paid for a movie was a movie called mr
woodcock which wasn't a huge hit but it
was a it was a fun movie and the next
thing i did was television and i did
television for five years and you know
if you if you do a television show for
seven months straight you want to take
those five months off you don't want to
go and do another movie so i'm going
there bob thornton yeah so they're
coming banging a teacher or something
what was that what was that whole thing
he he was the the mean
pe coach okay that then starts hooking
up with one of the moms right and um
you know
not stifler's mom but
right stiffler's mom yeah that's not
stiffer than that right
um
coming out of my name is earl my name is
earl ends i've not done a movie in a few
years and now i'm like okay let's go do
movies again and movies were kind of
like well
we you're a tv guy now you know and so
then it was doing pilots and and more tv
series so
i you know i can't say it's only weight
loss that has
you know what i mean yeah so this paid
you the most
until today
of any movie ever any movie yeah this
paid you the most wow what was your role
in this movie can you pull up um i
played his best friend and and me and
him were
you know trying to track down dirt on
uh woodcock to to break up him and his
mom
but see i wasn't i wasn't i wasn't at
that point as big as i wasn't remember
the titans no not even close
no not even close you uh
what what do you weigh there no you're
you're smart
300 pounds there
well well back to the jonah hill thing
about i think there's there's a part and
even with your situation there's a part
of i think just the human condition i
don't know if this is hollywood but when
you're so used to something and you
change you're like oh that's not who you
are you're the fat guy what are you what
are you doing right right you know
you're on the tv buddy what do you want
to do exactly like that's part of that
once you do tv and it's like it's a
successful tv show people are like no
you're that character right when you're
doing movie after movie especially me
where i'm not a leading man so i'm not
the guy in the movie you know denzel
washington people probably have some
sense of i know who denzel washington is
right he's this guy right and if he
suddenly did a sitcom people would be
like what the [ __ ] is denzel washington
doing he's not a sitcom guy you know
where he's playing like the goofy dad
people would be freaked out that would
be freaked out yeah so would i yeah um
and so tv people you know the the other
differences it was explained to me once
was
like um brad pitt i believe
and i could be totally off here brad
pitt was talking to johnny galecki
johnny galecki was on roseanne and then
um that math sitcom i'm blanking on what
it's big bang big bang theory yeah
blonde dude no he's got oh no no the
glasses he was okay he was darcy's
husband so roseanne
johnny galecki had a 100 million dollar
contract on that show he was making a
fortune and
and
brad pitt said to him yeah the
difference between you and me is you are
inside their house every week you're in
their living room i'm in a movie theater
so
people are not coming up to me going hey
like people actually think
they know you when you're on tv versus
when you're a movie star there's some
separation you got to go and and it
might be changing
very interesting it might be changing
now because a lot of these movies are in
the house too immediately right but it's
also not serialized so it's like this is
it this is the movie you don't get uh an
episode two
through possibly 100 of a movie
right but when you're when you're
you're kind of talked about like you're
that guy you're that i mean
a lot of people in hollywood or even in
tv struggle with that i mean like
dustin diamond no matter what role he
ever did that was screech yeah straight
up mario lopez who uh hosted one of uh
pat's
um big events mario's been able to
navigate he's not ac slater when you see
that guy
still he's everywhere he's everywhere i
mean
i see a hotel yeah and and the way my
career started in movies i was in
american history x and then remember the
titans and then blow those are three
very very different characters right and
so you're not i'm i'm
massive in all of them but you're not
pigeonholing me into oh i know
everything about that guy because then
the next week i'm doing something
completely different or the next
what do they say when they see you like
was it different based on different
movies that were out like when people
see you in public what would it what
would they say it really is
it it depends on their age and what
they're interested in was there and ever
a person that was upset with you because
who you were in a movie a role you
played in the movie i have had you know
what i'm asking you i have had a few
people upset with uh american history x
and offended by it and i'm i'm kind of
perplexed because i think american
history x was actually an important
movie and and pain
you painted a real picture of stuff that
happened especially you from los angeles
you know orange county in the 90s was a
scary place there were some bad dudes
down there that stuff existed i don't
think it really exists like that as we
portrayed it i mean i'm sure there are
pockets in america but there were it was
easy to go down to orange county and
find some racist skinheads in the 80s
or the 90s
not so easy now um but like it was
important in that way and so to have
somebody just like the language was bad
you guys were so evil i can't believe
you did that it confuses me yeah that
that's that's kind of how i process it
like somebody comes oh you you know what
you you did this
and because emotionally you're connected
to the movie you're like i can't believe
you killed them in a movie do you think
that's more related to tv shows though
or movies
but people don't seem to have a problem
with any of the tv shows i've done
really interesting but is that also due
to the characters because i know for
instance there are certain characters
like you mentioned in the tv shows where
they're in the in the living room week
after week year after year in many cases
and stuff like that where there's tv
shows where i think of a bad guy and
that's all i see him as even when you
see him in a movie in a different in a
different role you're like no you're
that dirtbag from that from that tv show
yeah and i think that given that you're
in there longer and you're playing that
role as opposed to a movie where you're
a bad guy for two hours and then i go on
with my life
maybe that could be more of an offset as
opposed to the tv [ __ ] i've played so
few bad guys i've played really like one
i'm trying to rack my brain other than
american history like i don't think
there's another one that i've done where
i've been like a real legit bad guy is
that by choice or is that by casting
i i have nothing against playing a bad
guy i just haven't had many
opportunities
i'm a sweet guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
they don't see you as a new elastic baby
two things i want to ask before we
before we uh some you know one of them
has to do with uh
uh where you're at one is uh are you
following the disney story what's going
on with disney
very loosely i personally don't watch or
pay attention to the news at all i'll
read some articles but i i think i have
an understanding of it by the way
disney's been canceled so many times by
so many groups over the years it's just
like some people are mad at disney now
okay
it's what you're saying it's it's
constant that happens constantly they're
constantly being cancer it's just not
the first time in my lifetime of being
aware of disney that there's been a
group pissed off at disney this is
slightly different though this is
slightly different because you know
uh you know
charlie cora did you see the story with
charlie cora uh disney uh airs and high
school teacher comes out as trans slams
florida educational law you know the
great grandchild of the late roy disney
who co-founded disney with the younger
brother walt has come out as transgender
is going to on the attack against
florida's parental rights and education
law cora said that lgbtq
people already face rates of depression
anxiety bullying and suicide they put
then put aside
something like that as a law they can't
learn about our community and their
history or play sports or use bathroom
they want to use the claim is not
entirely true the education bill only
prevents florida
so
you know you said something interesting
you said back in the days
it was them trying to silence uh uh
you know
what group were you people on the right
people on the rightness uh the skinhead
not skinhead it was weirdness
yeah and then today now is this the
extremes being on both sides
but uh i think the pendulum swings man i
think i think it swung radically left
and unfortunately it's gonna swing
radically right yeah probably and so for
me i don't find that i
really can get down with either of those
extreme sides i'm i'm a guy who's just
like i'm interested in people i find
people fascinating i'm interested into
the solutions people have and i'm
interested in all of it i i don't want
to like discount anybody but but
this
this whole thing over this law in
florida
i read the law the law is not
saying what they're saying the law is
saying for me
i don't want
i i mean
it doesn't seem like an opportune time
to teach kids about sexuality from
kindergarten to third grade that's my
perception on kids so the idea of not
teaching them that not informing them on
things like that especially
i think that should be the job of the
parents
so i don't understand why they're so
freaked out about it by the way there's
nowhere in the bill that it says don't
say gay
nowhere in the bill yeah that's just
called great marketing but but one of
the things that uh wanted did you want
to say something i was going to say you
you brought up yesterday the pendulum
swings yeah we're bringing it about
today i think that is america i mean not
even just politically societally
everything just comes down to i mean
think about it since 1980 we've had
reagan and then
pendulum's never gone right with disney
no i'm not even saying disney i'm saying
then you go to bill clinton and then you
go back to bush and then you go to obama
and then you go to trump and then you
can like that's america and then we're
just constantly grappling yeah disney
uses what the center of gravity is the
the cartoonists in disney used to put
dicks in the cartoons the little mermaid
and the bra you talk about the box yeah
and the box of little mermaids covered
that's what you're talking about but but
when it was in the actual stills they
would hide in the cartoons themselves
they would hide phalluses and
graphic stuff in all this
um
and and
they've removed a lot of it's not just
that you can like look for
instances of um graphic images in disney
cartoons what the hell is that all about
well i'm just saying there were times
where religious groups were furious with
disney about this well i'm just a normal
person not religious why are you hiding
dicks
it's just not the first time
people have been bent out of shape about
what disney and then there were there
was a time where
you know i don't think this is true yeah
right there that is it clearly a
[ __ ] and balls
[Laughter]
on the cover of the little mermaid i
remember someone behind the scenes is
basically saying i'm trying to ruin kids
lives obviously it impacted adam's life
i'm just saying i remember thinking
ariel was pretty hot and then i was very
angry with disney the left was angry
with disney because he wasn't unionizing
his workers so there was a time period
where disney was perceived as the right
but that's that's
anger from the left no i don't know i
don't know about that i think that's
different because and of course i know
the story i've been to the san francisco
disney museum that they have i don't
know if you've been there it's pretty
sick it's sick i mean it's app if you
ever go to san fran
you have to go to the disney museum it's
got a lot of good stuff there but
that's different didn't they call walt
disney a nazi or a nazi sympathizer
that's called everything
that's from the left i know i know but
what i'm saying is there's a difference
between
the en they're always going to target
the guy at the top of any company that's
that comes with the territory bro if
you're going to make a lot of money
you're going to have power you're going
to have influence shit's going to be
talked about you
this is trying to influence kids this is
different this is the ceo saying 50 of
the characters are going to be dot dot
dot
that that's influencing the kids
in a in a way that scares the crap out
of parents on both sides i don't think
it's political anymore because i think
regardless of your democrat libertarian
independent republican your parent first
if you got kids and you got four kids i
got four kids so we we look at it from a
different perspective and the florida
bill says third grade and i'm like dude
what third grade you shouldn't do until
high school what i don't care if it's
fourth grade you mean to tell me fourth
graders okay
when is sex ed
teach it then health and guidance is
that that's six or ten eighth grade that
was seventh grade there's two levels
yeah there's
yeah so the the banana and the the the
condom and then you got the health and
guidance i don't know why it's being
discussed before that to be honest i'm
we're on the same page i don't disagree
with you and by the way this next story
until maybe we'll take a caller uh john
if we have any callers let me know if we
do have call okay good so we got a uh a
story comes out um which is pretty
interesting on who's gonna be
challenging um so mike
mick
mulvaney says ron de santis tim scott
and dwayne johnson could seriously
challenge trump dwayne johnson trump in
2024 this is an insider story former
acting
white house chief of staff mick mulvaney
thinks just three people could seriously
challenge trump in 2024 for florida
governor desantis could give him a run
for his money south carolina tim scott
senator tim scott can give him a run for
his money as well as dwayne johnson
could give him a run for his money it's
a short list by the way there's one
other person who could beat him which is
myself donald trump is yeah myself
himself that's what he's talking about
donald trump is sometimes his own worst
enemy when it comes down to campaigning
so but i mean my main part with this
story isn't trump it's
dwayne hollywood running um can you see
you know rock running for office and
being a president can you see something
like that happening sometime i i
couldn't see trump doing it so i think
after trump
i think anybody oprah could be president
you know musk can be president
you can be for me it's just like who
would you like to see be president if
you're like would you see musk be
president of which i'm not talking about
like i'm not asking questions like
hillary clinton or i'm not talking a
political who would you like there's a
meme maybe you could pull it up vote for
nobody this is this is my political
philosophy to a t 100
um and and and this is this is what i
believe is the way
to the best future
that's it vote for nobody nobody will
keep election promises nobody will
listen to your concerns nobody will help
the poor and unemployed nobody cares
nobody tells the truth that is the
nobody part that is who i'm voting for
sounds like give government less power
you know i like that i kind of like you
know who's going to line up and vote for
that party nobody i am just yeah
john if you got any callers let's get a
couple callers here i think you said you
got a few lined up yeah we have alex on
the phone alex how are you
oh man what's going on mr pbd how you
doing man i'm doing good man so what's
your question what's your question for a
friend here
all right so a couple things ethan man i
love you and uh remember the titans man
i know people probably give you a lot of
uh
you know uh gus about that man but i
just want to tell you man you're still
one of my favorite actors out there both
on and off the screen um one of the
things i wanted to ask you personally
this morning was
um what was your greatest psychological
obstacle that you felt you had to
overcome in order to encourage um
the transformation that you underwent
you know i i started out and it's
possible because i had so many failures
that i was convinced that i would fail
and i think that there's that entering
into anything believing that you'll fail
is a is a
disaster it's a path to failure so it
was really kind of
turning my perspective around and and
and building small victories and
ultimately having belief that i could
succeed
awesome great question john let's go to
the next caller
who was it that said he who thinks he
can and he who thinks he can't is
usually right is right as a man think it
isn't that as a man think it i think
that's the author all right
we have aaron on the phone
aaron how you doing
good how are you guys man i'm good so
what's on your mind
um yeah so just uh coming from somebody
who's uh in their early twenties
uh i also went like
kind of through transformation i lost
more than 100 pounds and uh
i'm just wondering how like what advice
would you give somebody um in the early
20s ethan to kind of like prevent them
from developing those bad habits again
and just like staying focused and just
you know keep pushing it through i guess
yeah so this is this is great and i love
this because this is what i think about
more than anything
for me time and time again i had a goal
i want to lose x amount of pounds i lose
x amount of pounds and then my goal is
over and then i gain weight again
because i am programmed to gain weight
so how do i unprogram myself and really
it's about having the goal be
maintenance and maintenance
eating within a zone where you're
neither going to gain nor lose weight is
much harder because it's it's it's
teaching yourself basically how to eat
and that's the thing that i've worked on
more than anything else because for me
losing weight is not that hard i eat a
little bit less it might be miserable
it's for a very short period and then
it's over and then i eat whatever i want
and i gain weight again and it's like
how do we get out of that so it's really
having the goal be i don't want to be
morbidly obese ever again okay how do i
do that and then i can get more and more
more specific but setting these very
long-term goals
rather than just i'm going to
concentrate on this hundred pounds
because once you're done with 100 pounds
you've crossed the finish line you're no
longer doing it and you're just going to
be doing what you were doing before that
got you to the place where you needed to
lose 100 pounds
do you like being this guy like meaning
people could ask you about hollywood
movie stuff all day but people are
really fascinated by your transformation
your weight loss you do you relish
this is why people want to talk to you i
i i love anything that keeps me
accountable anything so i want to talk
about weight loss as much as possible
because
i've lost 100 pounds four times i've
lost 200 pounds multiple times and then
i've gained it back and it's [ __ ]
mind-shattering and destroying to wake
up one day and realize i had gotten
there and i went back and so i never
want to go back again and as much as i
can talk about it i'm happy when's the
last time you were like 300 plus or a
weight you're just like i do not like
myself 2000
2017 or 18. this is pretty recent yeah i
mean i've i've maintained this for four
years it's pretty solid though for four
keep it up bro yeah we're gonna hold you
accountable we're gonna have you back on
you better be [ __ ] looking great
thank you
uh real quick alantino asked a question
in the chat um what do you think of
johnny depp and and the fact that he's
on trial right now do you have any
thoughts about that i really liked
johnny depp when i worked with him i i
that was also
over 20 probably 25 or 26.
and he was a real sweetheart i i just
the thing the whole thing makes me sad
he seems like a great guy and he's lost
all his roles with disney over this and
he loved being a part of disney movies
alice in wonderland pirates of the
caribbean and they've ripped him out of
everything because of this this trial
yeah and it seems like he's just getting
absolutely screwed over nothing yeah i i
it makes me very sad i i don't know what
to say beyond that i i don't know the
details by the way you know what um
johnny depp and elon musk have in common
they both were married or dated the same
girl you ever heard right
mate i think i think she went from
johnny to elon musk like that it was
close to the same yeah
i don't know what's going on in the
water with this chick amber herd but
yeah we have one more call she's doing
some some magic on men go for it
john you're live
oh okay hey pat how you doing john
i'm doing astonishing i'm at work right
now i love it what's on the question i
have for you is uh is this offer that
elon is making
to twitter to buy out the whole company
with an astonishing premium is that too
good to resist and with bezos owning
um washington post does elon go for like
new york times next you know not like
cnn cnn i don't think it's very uh
redeemable at this point even with elon
at the helm
um but new york times i think would be
an opportunity for england to capture i
for them to let
them buy new york times i don't think he
would do new york times because i don't
think that excites him i don't think
it's fast enough for him i think new
york time is slow and it's a little
older although i think he should buy new
york times if it goes for sale just to
add it to his uh you know portfolio of
companies he's owning
the question you got to ask is the
following here's a question you got to
ask
when he makes an offer like that people
wake up this morning i just made an
offer you know people make an offer to
buy a baseball card people make an offer
to buy a car or a house this guy makes
an offer to buy a freaking company right
okay
good morning here's an offer there's
going to be three people in that board
room in the company there's going to be
those who are going to be like hell
yeah i want the money we're good do it
okay
then there's going to be those in the
middle that are actually processing this
decision
and they're not processing it from a
negative place or a positive place
they're just saying what does this look
like let's negotiate the terms right
they're actually coming from a place of
i want to hear both sides of the story
very you know independent kind of
thinking but you have to ask the
question who does not want elon to buy
this do you think the existing ceo wants
elon to buy this i say hell to the no do
you think the media wants ilan to buy
this you know the answer to that
question do you think everybody in the
government wants ilan to buy this of
course not every time the company the
government has meetings with ev
ceos there's only one evco they don't
invite and it's the guy who created the
trend of electrical vehicles elon musk
and oh he's not invited we missed him on
the list how the hell does that make any
sense it's like saying let's recognize
the top 50 greatest basketball players
of all time and you don't invite michael
jordan what happened there you know we
just kind of figured we bring everybody
else but mike so yeah you got to ask the
question on this deal getting done or
not i trust capitalism because i think
the people in the middle will tilt to
the right the people on the right that
are like i'm just doing a business deal
yeah let's take 40 this is a no-brainer
i mean
it's you got to ask who does not want to
see this happen and how much influence
are they going to have and how many
games are they going to play to make
sure elon doesn't end up buying twitter
that's my biggest concern uh real quick
got a 20 super chat uh passion planet uh
ethan what did you learn from the
character seth
from the character seth
um
oh
and what movie was this american history
x oh gotcha
i you know i learned
okay here here's the honest truth i went
into it with an idea of making this guy
a
cartoon and a caricature
and i learned that i was probably better
off making him a human being he's still
a little bit cartoonish because people
can be cartoonish but i i felt like at
the end of the day i wanted him to have
some humanity and that could be a bummer
to people but i i think that in
portraying anybody even if you go into
it knowing like this is a guy that lines
up polar opposite to me he's still a
person and so that was really the lesson
i took away from that i i've seen that
movie i don't know how many times it's
one of the
i mean acting beginning you i mean
everybody in that movie was like
the father the the table you know when
they're having the dinner or whatever
that was and he gives this eight nine
minute monologue and he goes off and the
scene on the sidewalk with the street oh
the side brother in the bathroom the
ending of the movie where you're crushed
as a viewer
it's a it's an it's an incredibly
profound movie with a message that kind
of like oh that's right that's right
like like
oh [ __ ]
that could also happen
that's what i like about the movie
because it's screwing up with both sides
everybody's kind of confused by the time
the movie's done yeah and everybody's
held accountable by the time this
movie's done uh very good movie where's
ed norton these days what's he doing i
just did a movie that he directed a few
years ago called motherless brooklyn
he's around he's still doing his thing
yeah yeah but he's not as
seen as much anymore is that purposeful
i think that's intentional really why is
it yeah i have no idea okay i have no
idea but he could do whatever he can
dude you're in like pat started the
episode off with all the names right
johnny depp matthew mcconaughey well
leonardo dicaprio
i don't know that i ever met matthew
okay forget about mcconaughey whatever
but the names are ridiculous okay ed
norton i mean
at any point or do you just like pinch
yourself be like dude i get to work with
the greatest [ __ ] actors of our
generation i pinch myself when i'm with
my kids and my wife and i have this life
that truly feels like a fairy tale to me
like i'm not kidding i
there was a point in my life when i was
a teenager where i thought like what do
you really want and it'd be a wife and
kids and i'd go like yeah that's never
gonna happen that's impossible to find
somebody that really loves you to have a
relationship that's meaningful to create
children and watch them grow and and
that for me honestly is when i pinch
myself and go check me out holy [ __ ]
look what i did i can't believe it
that's awesome
same feeling by the way as a father oh
you know it's crazy
this week we were at with joe for those
couple days and then we rented out
foxboro and i'm hanging out with
patriots players and i'm having my 97 of
my executives over there we're watching
man in the arena every episode we
watched together for two days and then
we had patriot players come including
tom's one of his
managers and they talked about what it
was like to create that kind of a
culture
do you know the entire time what i was
thinking about i was thinking about
coming home and seeing dylan and seeing
uh tico and cena in brooklyn it's crazy
there's a unique feeling with family
and and by the way you know when you're
saying like how's it feel knowing you've
acted with all these other guys
there's 50 million actors in the world
that would love to have had the career
that you've had bro you've had a
ridiculous career and not one year not
two year not three years not five years
how many years thirty thirty years dude
that's crazy to be able to say that
you're forty six thirteen sixteen was
the first gig you did what was the first
first big movie you did early uh first
movie mall rats
which
was
but then became like the most rented
movie at blockbuster for a while like it
became guys that did clerks yeah and uh
the whole
saga that they they did yeah silent bob
and uh jay and silent bob those guys
yeah that movie's 30 years old well very
cool man this has been great having you
on brother this was fantastic learning
about you learning about your story
uh and where you're at today you are an
inspiration i saw a video
of you on men's fitness with nine and a
half 10 million views
you're literally inspiring tens of
millions of people that's very very
because you know we had
david berlinski here yesterday and i
said what what how do you describe to
your son what it is to be a man like
what is it what is the purpose of a
man's life and he gave
you know his example of you should be
like your grandfather because his
grandfather was like a legend
yeah he was like he was a man's man but
i think a part of life as a man human
being
is
to inspire others who are going through
challenging times that don't think there
is any way to get out of it and you're
like almost in a spider web
and you're stuck and you're trying it's
like that nightmare you have where
you're trying to run on the bad guys
chasing you just can't move you're like
stuck like this
and some people are living that in their
real life and a guy like you is
inspiring literally tens of millions of
people props to you of course you got an
incredible resume beautiful family that
you built and what you're doing with
your family uh uh you did the last few
sentiments you gave about that and
haven't worked with a lot of different
guys in the industry but uh you know at
the end of the day we somehow someway we
want to inspire others to also you know
do something with their lives just like
we did you're doing that it's powerful
it's powerful brother great having you
on the podcast my pleasure thanks for
having me yeah this was a blast folk i
don't know what is our do are we doing
something next tuesday or no so next
thursday i'm going over you're out of
town we're out of town all next week oh
shoot okay friday we may have
joe rogan's buddy yeah
oh tony tony oh man i had such a good
tony hitchcliff yeah he's hilarious i
was
dude i saw
i almost went let me tell you i'll tell
you one story i
literally i'm watching tony perform
and joe got us tickets right front run
i'm sitting i'm like tony tells a joke
says you know i get i get a uh the other
day
um one of my good friends was very
disappointed and he calls me was upset i
said what's that he says
man i'm not gonna lie to you you know i
found out my wife and i were expecting a
kid and it's gonna be a girl and i'm
heartbroken cause i wanted a boy he says
really he says yeah it says don't worry
nowadays just be patient she may end up
being a boy
hilarious oh my god this guy's funny
like he was unreal on how good he was so
maybe we'll have with them uh on friday
and then well we are not here next week
you're out of town seriously i had no i
know i'm out of town i just didn't know
we're not doing nothing next maybe
friday well listen i'll show you one
thing here that we got since we're not
going to be with you i got so many
things i want to talk to the guys about
we have so many topics youtube we just
got for this channel of course we have
this for we have a hundred thousand
thing for like five other channels we
have one with three million but we just
got one for the podcast which is all
because of you guys we just crossed a
hundred thousand for the pod
right across it a year 187
you know what we should do here's what
we should do maybe
maybe we do something like if we
uh let's put a timeline when we get to
250 we invite a couple of the listeners
to the podcast to come on join us with
the guests that we're going to have
maybe we'll announce that on the next
time but this wouldn't happen without
you guys obviously adam you've been on a
lot of these podcasts every guest every
co-host we've had everybody that we've
had on it's a help with all those folks
that have worked together on helping the
podcast and the guys in the back but we
got a couple other things that just came
in i think adam got a gift
did we open up this i don't know i don't
even know what this is they just brought
do you know what it is i have zero clue
all right let me see what this is
from the desk of dj anthony
uh let me see what this is so oh oh oh
you got a certificate of completion
what is this thing here
uh hey pat whoever's reading this you
recently asked on one of your shows for
viewers to send in something for the new
studio in his shelving
i thought a nice certificate would go on
the display shelving the best part is
you can choose who receives the soy boy
award
you know who's getting this anyways
great show you and your crew are an
inspiration and not because of money but
because of your friendship and family
continued success oh check out my
youtube channel too wellness week well
thank you for this he sent this out i
think this
obviously certificate publicly adam goes
to you congratulations
extraordinaire dj anthony respect how
many people are achieving four just
think about it just think about the
level of enlightenment how many people
woke up today went to work yeah and they
got a certificate for soy boys not a lot
of them you're part of an elite
community a lot of employees and fast
food restaurants are the employee of the
week employee of the month i'm the soy
boy of the year i am still curious to
know who gave that comment
of him being a soy boy because they
started something bigger than they did
anyway i had high expectations for this
episode and i think we it exceeded those
let me just
so these central boys decent roles are
artists who love creating fundraising
invite tim and pbd podcasts our fans
about your dedication entrepreneurship
and goal setting and making dreams
become a reality is a true inspiration
to us we were on one casual trading
cards we're thrilled to see your passion
for collecting cards yes as fans we are
the center of the rest of the delivery
of your custom trading cards as a gift
custom trading cards as a gift okay now
i have no clue what this is by the way
the guys told me you got to do this on
camera not only did we print out actual
pbd trading cards but we actually minted
them as nfds on the blockchain on opencv
on our own account the qr code on the
back of your trading card will direct
you to the web page of each individual
nft if you choose to claim your free nf
to each card you can simply reach out to
them somewhere else okay all right let's
see what this is that's pretty sick i
said what we got here man i do collect
cards or no no dude i love cards like
crazy
cards all right let's see what this is
[Laughter]
oh my gosh how do i open this oh that
picture just looks
oh my you guys is it you playing
baseball dude but i've never played
organized baseball these guys
how do you open this thing can can you
open okay there we go juan gonzalez
wrote
guys
looking like ty cobb over here amazing
look at this like i'm seeing this
formula one this they created this stuff
oh this is an error
valuetainment pbd entrepreneur and it's
an nft it's literally nft okay we got a
few of them unbelievable look at this
one here i look like uh uh uh that that
uh man this is mickey mouse looking
looking like senna right here this is
something for itself well first of all
toshi and the boys you guys are freaking
sick this is awesome this is ridiculous
i love this gift thank you guys much
love to you guys and we are definitely
going to go out there and uh uh look at
the qr code and claim it
uh
tyler can you put their handle uh in the
comments section so people can find them
the central boys like central d
central central boys with a z
boys with a z d central boys as their
instagram account uh and their twitter
account fellas thank you for this
appreciate your freaking sick sick gift
awesome i love it you need gifts anyways
uh i i wasn't gonna do it today with you
because this was about you i i normally
wouldn't open up a gift with a guest but
we're not here next week so we're kind
of doing this today uh but i had a blast
gang we'll miss you next week we may be
together on friday take care everybody
bye bye bye bye
you